(light playful music)
- You see, gentlemen,
I'm gonna be president
of the United States.
Now I don't say that impress you
or to seem terribly precocious.
I'm merely stating a fact.
I will be president someday
because I will stop at nothing.
(light playful music)
And as student body president,
I will ensure that every student
at this school has an equal
opportunity to succeed.
If you choose to honor me by electing me,
I will fight for each and every one of you
so long as there is
strength in me to fight.
(light playful music)
I'm not a good person, all right?
I try to do good things right,
but I'm not a good person!
That's my flaw.
(light playful music)
- We need to break up.
- You said you wouldn't judge me!
- Not really break up, we
need to pretend to break up
in order for you to win the election.
(light playful music)
- You're gonna change the world, Payton.
- How do you know?
- Because I see you.
(light playful music)
- My loyalty is with you, Payton.
This is a plane.
We're all headed to the same place.
You're the pilot, James
and I are your navigators.
- Neither one of us knows
how to fly like you can.
We need you to get us to the White House,
but we wouldn't be doing our job
if we weren't being honest with you.
If we don't tell it like
it is, we'll all crash.
(light playful music)
- Not to toot our own horns,
- Toot!
But we've won karaoke night
at the Wapakoneta Summer Cheer Camp
every year since we were three.
It's in our blood.
(light playful music)
(eerie discordant music)
- Screw you very much, Payton.
Hell of a campaign.
(light playful music)
- We should have him assassinated.
Too dark?
(light playful music)
- I think that everyday is a gift.
And every time that I
wake up, even if I have
to get a platelet
transfusion from Dr. Singal,
I think to myself,
a lot of kids around the world
don't have the same
medical care that I do,
so if that's what I have to go through,
that's God's plan.
(light playful music)
- I might have some
psychological problems, you know?
And I think
I probably need to get some help.
(light playful music)
- Wow, just wow.
(boys slapping hands)
- Boys, boys!
Boys, you stop that right now!
This negative energy is not
good for your father' healing.
(light playful music)
Your generation got the terrible idea
that it was best to vomit every thought
and feeling all over each other.
It's a pandemic of overcommunication
that's led to an absence of intimacy.
(light playful music)
- The only shame I feel
is when I look at you.
You're a quitter and a loser
and the greatest
disappointment of my life.
(light playful music)
- I'm not happy.
I don't wanna hate my life anymore.
- Not happy is not a reason
to put us through all of this.
Not happy is what antidepressants are for.
(light playful music)
- Should we be worried?
- Worried? (laughs)
No.
This is gonna be fun. (laughs)
We're gonna eat him alive.
(light playful music)
- I am tough,
but I'm no cookie.
(light playful music)
- Do not screw with my dream, all right?
I'm on a singular path, 'kay?
(light playful music)
♪ Dream on but don't imagine
it will all come true ♪
♪ When will you realize
Vienna waits for you ♪
♪ All things go, all things go ♪
♪ We had our mindset ♪
♪ You have to find it ♪
♪ All things go ♪
(light playful music)
- Oh ho ho, well hot damn!
- You live over on Hermosa Road, right?
What many would consider the
other side of the tracks?
(light playful music)
- I'm turning over every
one of these firearms
to the Santa Barbara
County Sheriff's Department
who will deliver them this afternoon
to the Dowell Aluminum
and Foundry in Carpinteria
to melted down into steel rebar
that sophomore Dallas Weintraub
will then sculpt into
an abstract art piece
about America's gun violence epidemic,
which will premier this June
at Santa Barbara's ForReal Gallery
as part of this year's Downtown Arts Walk.
(light playful music)
They took those morons!
- Well, your father and
I bought their way in.
We were very clear.
You said you wanted to do this properly.
- No, no, I can't get in
that way, people know it.
It stays with you.
It's handing your opponent in
a negative ad on a platter!
(light playful music)
(people clapping)